in our business we're mostly a beer
company but we also have a big Pepsi
business in the Americas and we're the
biggest Pepsi bottles outside of the US
so we have a lot of contacts with Pepsi
we exchange best practices we visit them
a lot and we've done that for almost 20
years every time I would come to Pepsi
here in the US to visit exchange copy in
our language
I would always copy a lot of things in
pricing execution go to market
throughout to market strategy
distribution there was one manual that
they would always try to hand it to me
that I never really I said no no I have
I already have too much to carry in the
plan which was a manual leadership it
was a 57 page manual with 57
characteristics of a good leader and in
those days you know we're pretty much in
South America and I said man this thing
at leadership is too much of an American
concept you know I mean I mean it's
about movies Hollywood's you know West
Point it's not for us you know we do it
differently you know leadership
I'll not carry that book and it's funny
because I evolved I had a I was most of
my time in the company I've been in the
head of sales so for me sales was
everything and I was famous in the
company to say you know what everything
else doesn't matter I don't care I mean
it's all about sales if I don't sell you
don't produce if I don't sell don't hire
anybody so it's all about sales
that's what matters everything else is
kind of back office and I was very
radical and not today and and then my
CEO at the time the guy reported to tell
me know what Brito we're going to
promote you from head of sales to head
of operations and that is people we
don't call a human resource we call
people manufacturing procurement and
some some other boring thing and it said
and I said wait a minute I mean my
results are pretty good okay we're
having a tough start of the year but if
you look at the last ten years I mean
I've had the track record while I being
demoted and it said no no no no trust me
I mean this is good for your career you
know it's going to be good you're going
to be the CEO of the company one day
right I said well that's my dream and it
said okay but then you need to learn
that the company is not only about sales
that's the ultimate thing if somebody
buys what you're producing but that's
not all about sales and then it went to
this new function for two years and
guess what the thing that I really liked
the most about it was the people side of
things and that was really when I truly
understand what's behind everything I
was doing sales which was all around
this people thing so that's how I got
there and then I called Pepsi said by
the way that book that I always left on
the table can you send it to me that 57
we simplified that a lot because that
was a challenge to we you're going to
see about I'll talk about leadership
your philosophy and one thing we believe
a lot isn't being simple you got to do
simple things things that are easier to
understand because that has a much
bigger likelihood of success and people
understand you so when I saw 57 pages of
leadership I said this is not going to
work I mean Pepsi hasn't been doing this
for twenty years thirty fifty this is
our first year so let's start with
simple things and the first question was
okay a leader is born or made that
famous question right then you read some
maps and literature that says that only
2% of the population are born leaders
and it said man if I go with this theory
it's going to be tough we need a whole
bunch of leaders here if I believe that
only 2% of them and if I hit that right
2% are going to be leaders in this
company so I hypothesize I decided to go
with the other theory that said that you
can form and get people to be better
leaders
so we started like that and then I said
but what's the leader and we define it
very simply a leader somebody who needs
a team to achieve his or her targets
that's it
if you are working number crunch alone
you're not living in a leadership
position right there because you can do
your job yourself but if you're leading
a sales division if you're leading a
plant if you're leading a finance
organization you need people to help you
get there and that's when leadership
skills will play a role and then we said
okay but what's a good leader and we
define it instead of using 57 things we
said three things very profound things
but three things we said littered a good
leader is all about delivering results
in a sustainable basis doing it with the
team because again the very definition
cannot do it alone
doing with the team and everything that
goes along with the people side of
things and doing it right so you can
replicate you can build on top you can
do it again you do it wrong you have to
redo it but go back to square one so
it's all about delivering results with
the team do it the right way and then
you say okay now I understand leaders
can be formed to be trained you can
enhance their skills you know what your
expect from a leaders results team do it
the right way you know that in some
positions you need a team you need to be
a leader but what's expected from a
leader how you build for example our
company the question we always had is
how do you build the high performance
culture and it's a little bit of a
buzzword once you have a 20 year track
record I think you can look back and say
well some of the things work how you
build a high performance culture and
what we did as leaders we learned that
you have to do three things in terms of
content to lead a company first thing
you have to have a dream that you
announce to the organization that's a
powerful enough dream that will inspire
people motivate them give a sense of
purpose will align people get them to
run in the same direction that's key
you're going to be the size of your
dream we learned that time and time
again and I'm not saying this because
it's a nice thing to say
it's pragmatic we learned that they
didn't know why we learned it because we
learned one day we realized that we
didn't have a company we had a
collection a group of people that we
call the company there's also such a
thing as embed where I'm bad or for that
matter Brahma in the old days what we
had is myself an 85,000 colleagues of
mine around the world 30 countries
that's the company and as individuals we
would like to have dreams I had a dream
of coming to Stanford at once I had a
dream of having somebody financing me to
come to Stanford at once you know my
life I had a dream of dating somebody
buying a car
my house going travel somewhere so those
things that moves you on a daily basis
when you wake up Monday morning if
you're a man holy cow
it's too cold outside and then you have
a purpose a sense of purpose but some
people overdo that a little bit and they
announce things to organizations that
are more like adventures than dreams
dreams are stretched by nature you're
not going to dream about something small
you know you're dreaming about something
big it takes the same amount of energy
that's the first lantern to dream big or
drink small to dream big or dream small
takes the same amount of energy so why
not stretch a little bit so dream is
stretched by definition four eyes dream
is that kind of thing that you know 70%
how to get there and you believe that
the balance the 30% you learn on the way
as your trip over things as you learn on
the way adventures the opposite you have
no idea how to get there you just think
it's a good sentence to say we want to
be best in five years guess what people
don't buy it because they it's not
credible they say hey man we know 20% o
to get there 80% to discover long to
wait five years I don't buy that I'm not
going to commit myself my life to this
that's crazy
gotta go somewhere else so the first
thing you have to have is a drink that
really inspires people give a sense of
purpose a sense of direction and
everything else that comes from it
belongs to this if you don't buy into it
our dream for example in the in the
different phases it was always to be the
best in classroom what we're doing and
we had ways to measure it profitability
volume growth and all that and that
inspired people because the only part of
a winning team so that's the first thing
the second things what we call the whole
people you know issue the realization is
that when you go to the service industry
it's very it's very easy to realize that
people is the most important asset that
a bank or consulting company has it's
the kind of asset base that goes home
every night in the elevator goes down
your asset base goes home every night
and you just hope that the asset base
will come back in the morning again to
work and to keep the business moving
forward when you go to consumer goods
you tend to think that what matters is
really the brands you have the trucks
the warehouses the plants all the
physical things you can see as a
consumer
but what we realize is that behind all
those things you have again great people
so to have a great brand that was
because somebody or a group of people
had the right insights understood
consumers needs occasions and knew how
to fulfill that on a day-in day-out
basis and do how to execute that people
anybody can build a plant but to have a
plant that churns great products great
efficiency it's all about people the way
they manage the plant so the asset
anybody can have it but the software the
people that's what matters
and we realize a lot of things about
people first very complex animal to deal
with human beings very complex we're all
very complex because we won't we won't
at all you won't make money you want to
be recognized you want to be heard it'll
be part of a winning team you want to
make a difference you're going to be
lady something you going to be involved
in the best part of the company terms of
growth and all that so you want all this
and you have to manage this if you want
to have the best people it's funny
because I never heard of companies
saying our intent is to have the very
average people in the marketplace never
heard that I think every company would
say it's an but what we realize is it is
one thing is to say the other things
practice for example great people that's
one thing we learn great people attract
more great people that's obvious but the
opposite learn is even more dangerous
that made yoga people attract more the
same and if you're in a company if
you're leading a group it can only be as
good as your group and if you start
being you know nice to people in the
sense of well Mike's a nice guy but it's
not very good but it's been here for 10
years and you know well next year we'll
talk about this you know the people
reveal this year you know yeah he didn't
made it but yeah we know let's give him
another chance and give the feedback and
all that and then 15 years later you're
still with the same problem and that's
when you start going off track because
you say you want to have the best people
you attract the best talent but then the
young talents like you are looking at
Mike a blocker and say man this
companies say one thing there is
something a little different so they do
can people attract more the same they
like to work together they don't
challenge that you buy you know each
other they
they say can you target will do it great
people are different they want to learn
they want to be surrounded by the same
kind of people you know what great
people like we learn talented people
what they like in a company in a company
environment they like a place where they
have meritocracy you may talk to see
it's tough it's tough it's a word that
everybody would agree nobody would be
against it would say no I don't think we
have talked us is right I think it's
seniority you should promote people save
yard how long they are in the company
you know so meritocracy they like
informality and they like candor so
simple but so hard to execute I always
say is the same thing if you want to be
in good shape so simple isn't it you
have to eat well exercise but how many
of us catch yourself sometimes not doing
it so it's the same thing about the
company and about leadership
everything is very simple very
common-sense thank God but the
difference is between the ones that do
it and the ones that think they're doing
it so for example what does Mike example
in our company we think to be fair with
people's to treat different people in
different ways most companies would not
be able to say that because they would
say that goes against something we
recognize that in our company we have
85,000 people but 200 250 are really the
ones that make a difference and that's
again being pragmatic not say it's the
correct thing to say or not but it's
pragmatic 250 people in our company make
a difference these people they are
managed in a different way because we
wanted to make sure they are excited and
not going to leave the company they're
going to grow at a faster pace
they're going to grow at the pace of
their talents no matter how senior or
junior they are to the company they
belong to that group we need to make
sure that these guys are engaged and
giving everything they have to grow our
business ok so there's a couple of
things about people the other thing we
would like to do with people is create
this environment where people feel
attracted and they will stay
meritocracies one thing is said you
think well that's obvious you know that
the guy who has a best track record most
potential should progress
but how many times you're going to find
yourself a company that will say yeah
but Mike you know has been here for 10
years and you know let's give him an
opportunity you've been here for two
years so you have time you're young your
weight and how many companies will do
that and for you making a decision it's
much live - it's much easier to live
with that kind of decision where you
promote people because most people would
say oh that's right Mike deserves the
opportunity you know but what about Tom
worldwar about Jane and pretty soon the
talented people will start going away so
everything else I'll tell you here today
it's so simple so common sense but so
hard I could pay this to go into the
church every Sunday I mean the Bible has
been there for 2,000 years and we still
don't get it right we have selective
hearing selective memory so you go there
you only get that 5% that you can cope
with get a 95 you okay I forgot and then
next year you go again that's the thing
about leadership
everything is so simple but it's so
tough not to get sidetracked because
there are so many distractions people
isn't one of those things there's a
professor that was here when I was here
Jim Collins he was a professor here he
was my professor as a company we've been
in touch with him since 1993 and he
wrote good - great book I'm sure you all
know and every December for the last
four years we go to Boulder mate with
him and the board and the whole thing
and once I asked him I said Jim let me
ask you this man I read your book again
it's so much about common sense why why
would any company do anything different
than that why would any company choose
to be good as opposed to be great
according to your definition in your
findings and it said Brito you know what
in my research what I found is that all
companies start with the right ideas but
the problem is that the good companies
don't understand or better saying the
great companies understand that it takes
time to build a great company it's brick
by brick and it's very tough it requires
a lot of resilience good companies think
that there must be an easy way there
must be a shortcut and that goes with
people as well how many companies will
come here hire NBA have a training
program but that's a lot of work
you have to come here you have to do
recruiter you have to develop you know
five years later the guy will start
giving something back to you as opposed
to some companies that says hey I can
short-circuit this process I'll just go
to the market hire somebody from a
marketing a great marketing company has
been 10 years in the marketplace has
been formed by somebody else or just
bring it you know to join our company I
don't need to do all this training
program and behave recruiting I guess
what those guys will come with a
different culture different mindset in
normal in our experience it doesn't form
a great team because you have people
from all over with different ideas on
how to run the business and different
values and that doesn't get the company
to be a great company the other thing is
that ok so you have this dream you have
the best people that you try to attract
and it's tough there are a lot of
temptations to get up sigh attracted and
we always say you should hire people
that can be better than you because it's
it's tough right you ask ok we want to
hire the best people in marketplace and
you say ok how you do how do you define
best people it is so cute I don't know
exactly how to define it but I say if
it's better than us it's already better
for the company right if we're hiring
somebody with the right training right
opportunities and the right time can get
to a position better than we are today
the company would be better off so
that's already a thing we say and we say
leaders are measured by the quality of
their team's that's important so we have
to realize that even if for if for
selfish reasons even if you don't
believe in all I'm saying you should
have a great team as a leader because if
you do that you're going to be able to
get to your targets you know faster and
you're going to be able to be promoted
faster because people when they look at
you they'll say no has such a great team
so has people to replace him or her so
yeah it's right time to give him a
chance to to go further so even for the
wrong reasons you get to the same place
people are the most important that's the
only competitive advantage today we see
is that it's funny because when we did a
merger in Brazil many years ago we had
an opportunity to merge with a
competitor and it's how many times you
have the chance to do that in the same
market and we said okay why are we
performing all this year is much better
than these guys maybe they don't have
the processes we had maybe they'll have
the
three things were developed you know
what we got there they had everything
every numbered copies we had that we
thought it was top secret that all
everything was copy there but it was all
on the shelves
nothing was implemented and the only
thing that could explain performance
they had some brands that were different
better than ours the only thing we could
put our fingers on was the kind of
people that we attracted the sense of
purpose that our people had in building
this great company that will be there
forever and beat everybody else and the
way to do this the shared mindset the
culture which I'm going to talk now one
of the things that in our culture is
very important it is idea of ownership
we believe that owners make better
decisions why because they live with the
consequences that's the only reason
whenever they do a trade off between
risks and and the decision they have to
make if they own the company they feel
like they own the company they will do
it with a mindset that well I'll be here
next year ten years from now helps
compare that to a rental car I don't
know maybe it's only happens with me but
whenever I Drive a rental car I try a
lot of things
I take old insurance and I try a lot of
things you know one of the things I like
to try first time was what happens if I
if the car is to moving forward and I
stick to reverse then how many of you
guys have this curiosity isn't that I
mean like with my car I never had the
guts to try it because I say well what
about it doesn't work and I have to live
with this car tomorrow the next month
next year next five years so in a rental
car why do people act differently I
think I think it only happens with me
I'm sure you guys ride the same way yeah
going through a bump to see if you can
get four wheels off the ground I'm sure
it only happens with me but and and then
you say well why do I Drive my car a
different way because that's my car it's
going to be mined tomorrow so live with
the consequences of my trials so we
don't want to be a rental company in the
sense that people come for a job they
come here for a job join our company
you'll try their best
they'll try a couple things risky things
it doesn't work they'll go to next job
that's something we don't like it that's
why we try to have an environment in our
company be it with targets the way
people participate compensation the
whole bonus system the whole thing - so
people understand that we own this
company and therefore whenever you make
a decision be aware that it's going to
be your decision for for many years you
have to live with that not the rental
car that's somebody else the next day
we'll pick up the pieces so but I'm sure
it only happens with me I think also
ownership is a great concept for us
because owners know that they have to
earn it every day I mean if you own a
bakery and the Walmart opens up in front
of you and you say Minh why me why me I
mean my family has been in this business
for three generations I mean we do the
best bread in town we make the best
bread in town now Walmart's selling for
one tenth of the price one stop shopping
with the big parking lot and all that
convenient in and out and Here I am what
about my clientele but that's life you
know so there's whole thing about
understanding that you have to earn it
every day
you're not entitled to anything two more
in our business if everybody consumers
decide to stop by our products we have
no business
so we have to sell beer today we have to
sell Pepsi every day that's it
so this idea is a powerful one there's
an ownership idea for example in our
company we don't have we're all like
options
well like shares because shares you go
up and down with the shares you only
shares options you only I have the
upside that's not the ownership
ownership is upside and downside if you
own that bakery you're going to go with
it up and down
that's what with its true ownership
press we also like in our culture where
we talk a lot about focus on results
against so obvious but so powerful I
mean focus as a leader one of the things
that people look most that you will
what's on the top of your list what are
the things we need to do to succeed and
focus is very important I remember times
I remember when I became a CEO in 2003
of the old company and again always been
in sales I had that brief passage
demoted to operations learned a lot and
when he came back CEO position I we had
a competitor of us of ours in Brazil
that took 10 percentage 10% of our
market share three months we had 68
percent market share all sudden we had
63 they did a great launch very well
executed and we lost solar market share
in three months and the markets were all
around us investors and say hey what's
going on we thought you guys had a good
grip there and and I remember the the
thing that that year we failed is that
that year we felt things are so good
that we said you know what let's try to
do more things so let's try to do more
innovation more activities in the
marketplace more promotional activities
more more more more and at the end we're
cloth our execution capability so we
went off again that's one say it's so
simple focus of course that white will
agree but sometimes you think you know
what sees it so well it's do things a
bit faster so the things that were
planned for next shields do this here
together with something else and then we
got so much the eye the eye off the ball
that we lost that then we
and six months we're back but that's the
kind of learning focus very important
leadership selecting the right fuse
because if you select the wrong fuse
then you're in trouble but selecting the
right fuse and giving people that
message that guys these are the things
that will move the needle this is the
must-haves everything else is a nice to
have but these are the things that will
make a difference did get a thing in our
in our culture that that we say a lot is
that we got to be always unhappy or
let's say have a healthy dissatisfaction
with our business we think that's key
and sometimes we criticize ourselves for
not enjoying the good moments so they
have good results and celebrate because
we're always I the next step but that's
you know you talk to two guys that are
good and what they do in sports and all
that that's that's what they say you go
to tennis player who just wants
something and you go to the interview
and the guy says oh yeah it was a good
game but I need to work a little bit on
my surf or but I was not you know my
back hurt a little bit so I was lining
100% shape so I need and the next
championship will be two weeks from now
and I need to prepare and I need to
train so this whole idea of never being
satisfied with the status quo again so
simple but how is a leader you instill
that and you get people to be always
unhappy with where they stand
the other thing is that that's very key
to our culture this whole thing about
north shortcuts I mean we we understand
and we try to give people that
understanding that we are a compliant
type company and what you learn time and
time again is that doing the things
right again it's a pragmatic thing it
pays off that's the kind of thing people
expect from you and it takes a lifetime
for you to build those credibility's in
those assets and you can destroy that so
easily with brands with consumers with
customers so that's yet a thing nor
shortcuts you cannot build a
great company if you're believe in
shortcuts if you believe in the
two-month diet book that was new in the
market that type of thing so you know
what the other thing we learn I mean I
talk about all this I talk about having
a dream I talk about having a the people
you know being the central focal focal
point of our development is a company I
talk about this culture of ownership
hard work focus results I talk about all
the things about no shortcuts but you
know what most people don't like that
that's amazing we go recruit in some
countries we have business in 30
countries what we find out is that our
culture is different than the national
culture so it is possible to have a set
of things you believe that you call
culture in China in Korea in Russia in
Brazil in Belgium Germany in the u.s.
everywhere
the national culture is different people
wait in different ways they spend a free
time with their families in different
ways and that's all fine and that's why
we're travel to see all the different
ways of doing things but when it comes
to the company we're very clear it's one
company one culture if you want to join
us try to understand the way we do
business that we were trying to to grow
a company very basic common sense like
things and if you agree with that great
join us but it's not no pun a lot of
other companies out there but what we
learned is that most people like the
average company what's the average
company the average company is the
company where people are promoted for
example more by seniority than by their
track records the average company is a
company that you know exactly where
you're going to be ten years from now
not very exciting but you know where
you're going to be the app site is
limited but the downside non-existent
the average company is a company that
doesn't differentiate people and the
average leader is the one that I promote
that the average leader thinks that
everybody should be treated the same
because that won't get me in trouble
the great leader is the one that
understands that different people
deserve to be treated differently not
taking about basic human rights I'm
talking about Korea opportunities and
that kind of thing
ah so what we see as we go through all
these countries where we have business
is that it is very hard to find people
that will be excited about the way we're
trying to build a business but once you
find them they get really connected to
company they cannot work anywhere else
because they love this kind of openness
candor for example is talking about
candor and before open to Q&A I didn't
really go too much into that so I was
saying people like openness they like to
know where they stand and that's a right
we always see in our company that the
way to treat people is always to tell
them where they stand and that's so key
think about that think about that Mike
example how many times you catch
yourself as a leader try to make the
sitter's for somebody else because you
think you know what's best for him or
her and you don't tell him or her what's
going away so the guy's not performing
doesn't have a bright future in the
company it's 35 years old so can still
go somewhere else
bright guy can still start the career
elsewhere but you think you're doing a
great thing for the guy but by by
keeping him in the company and then at
some point the guy is 45 and you finally
have to say you know what we tried for
10 years doesn't work so you're you're
out in other guy's 45 so I mean we all
we always say you have to be fair with
people life's too short to work for a
boring company or to be deceived and not
knowing where you stand
so I would say in summary what I learned
in all these years is that leadership we
started the business thinking that what
matter really was the whole thing about
attracting great people having the
technical and process knowledge we
learned I'll tell you one case last case
at one time in our company we were
having a problem many years ago of a
high turnover so he said man how come we
think this is the best company to work
for in the world and so many people
don't agree and they're leaving why is
that and we had a board member at the
time that was very much into people and
understood the power people what even
than we did and he said birthday know
what if you think people's the most
important thing in your company
let me tell this in pockets of your
business
in some countries you have a sick
population yet people are sick because
you have turnovers of 25 percent and
that doesn't build a great company and
people that are sick they cannot get
trained they don't learn they don't
progress they don't help the company and
that was very very strong to me at all
because you say turnover it's a
technical name but when you say SiC we
all know what it means
because it hits home and we did an
interview with all these people I mean
people that were leaving people that
were just joined people that were
old-timers in the company we did a
thousand introduced and what we learned
from all that is that leadership is this
invisible thing that was really missing
our company that's when we like called
Pepsi and asked for their manual because
guys were leaving the company because
they're saying you know what this
company has doesn't offer me
opportunities for growth and that was
not true we're growing like crazy I mean
we needed people all the time people
being from promoted from within but
perception is what counts and people had
the perception that their future was not
very bright they had they told us that
they were not always learning a lot from
their leaders from their supervisors
they told that they didn't understand
where the company was going and so all
this boils down to good leadership or
lack of it so that's when we started
realizing that more important sometimes
in process knowledge and management
knowledge knowing your industry or how
you process your business within that
industry is the leadership skills you
can do more sometimes even if you go to
different industry if you have those
skills and you surround yourself with
great people that will help you then on
the other things you don't know and you
have to learn then the other way around
and with that I'd like to open for
questions thank you very much
[Applause]
strong corporate culture and also
mention that you don't like mid-career
coming in because they have different
culture yeah any extent how you foster
creativity and diversity such as strong
culture corporation that's good point I
mean our culture as you say or the
culture I think a leader should
implement in a high-performance
organization is only a set of very basic
things it's like the US Constitution I
mean it's been there for 200 years
because it's very basic because if it
were too broad and too specific it would
have to be revealed all the time so the
set of things that we believe in 10
things as we call it the 10 principles
are so basic that we believe they can be
they're not going to deter creativity or
anything your second point about we have
a commitment with our people that 85
percent at least of all promotions will
be sourced from within because we think
that's the way to do it our best
experience is to hire people at this
level MBA or undergrad level leaving
school and creating these people in our
way of doing things because again it's
hard to find people that like this kind
of environment with more risk more
reward type environment people like
stable environments we like people that
like this environment what we do from
time to time and again it's not 100
percent from within is really higher
from outside but when we hired from
outside we do a big scrutiny because
this thing about culture is what is one
of those things that takes years to get
the fabric going but can be destroyed
easily that's why we say in our company
even if somebody has a great performance
great track record but no cultural fit
even after many sessions of feedback
this guy has to leave because the
culture is what got us where we are and
I think it's not only us it's any high
performance culture you see high
performance culture are very particular
about the way they do things and it's so
basic they would not want to change it
so everything is said here today it's
about common sense but believe me it's
very hard in a corporate world to stick
to it
but if you do it in my experience you'll
build a company that has credibility
that will attract great
we'll develop great people and because
the companies is what the people you
attract then you you can have a great
business yeah there was a question here
about now you can talk a lot about the
focus and attention to detail how do you
balance that with against developing a
tunnel vision and I denied seeing a risk
that's coming your way you're missing
some opportunities sorry Oh a dollar set
against what that developing a tunnel
vision and missing a risk that might not
be in your area of focus or missing an
opportunity that might be just around
the corner and because you're so focused
you might have not seen it yeah I mean
it's it's not that we don't for example
we have a soft drinks business I mean
that was one of those days that 20 years
ago we said you know what makes sense in
that part of the business to diversify
but today we see so many opportunities
in beer I mean in our business
especially in upgrading consumers you
know that we don't see why we should
look at other things at this point
you're right everything in life comes at
a cost I mean if you're too focused
maybe you're missing out on something
that a hand if you look at everything
you're missing out on everything
so you have to choose and that's one
thing about leadership leadership the
toughest thing about leadership apart
from all the things that I told you is
that people look at you in a year for
two or three decisions that's it if I
look at my ear I can pinpoint two or
three things that I was taught off who I
had to make a decision that was good or
bad but I had to make a decision and
that's it because one thing comes to you
it's because it's not black and white
it's stuff so this whole thing about
judgment this key you have to trust your
gut I mean it's great to have numbers
and all that for example when we do our
positions we run the numbers all the
seniors that we call it v1 v2 v3 all the
synergies and everything but at the end
what you do really is you go there you
talk to the people you kick the tires
you go in the market you talk to
consumers I mean you have to have that
smell that gut feel that this will work
because you know the mergers and
acquisitions and these things have a
high probability because of cultural
differences and all that of not working
on
adding the value we expected so I think
it's all about this judgment that is
required from leaders and it cannot get
away from it I mean because you could
say I come from business school
everything can be translated in numbers
and there's only one I always say people
when I went to school high school they
deceived me I would say that I was a
sieve that's cool
you know because they told me that every
problem comes with all that that the
numbers you need to resolve the problem
solve the problem any life forget it
that's not true they made me believe
that for every problem that was only one
solution that's also not true
there are many rights and many wrong
solutions especially again at our level
and yet a thing they made me believe is
that the best students will always be
the best leader which is not always true
I mean the best student has a lot going
for him or her but it's and I was good
one good one but you see that there are
many other things for example today I
was happy to hear that the school is
investing people skills and leadership
skills because when I look back at the
things I had 10 years ago here subjects
that was it that you feel it one that I
didn't take because I thought was too
soft I said I looked for the poets right
they call the poets I said now this for
poets I mean it's easy credits I'm an
engineer I'll go for finance corporate
finance and this and that yeah and then
when you go through life you understand
oh what that I know some of the things I
know today in terms of people and how
powerful that can be if you know how to
motivate inspire create a great team how
much easier it is to get to things like
that that would be great so long answer
satisfied
we balance well we get people
recognition for like 20 seconds and then
we go for next channel
that's how no we bounce well I mean
that's one thing you learn is sales I
mean every day is a different day so
just because I saw X amount of cases
yesterday has nothing to do with the
amount of cases I'm gonna sell today so
we do celebrate it not 20 seconds but
like you know a couple of hours and then
we're already talking about the next
month next week the next program but
you're right sometimes we get criticized
for not recognizing enough and yeah and
we say you're right that's one thing we
need to get better so maybe getting from
100 hours to 3 hours recognition then
way going to the next thing but it's a
tough balance you're right yeah right
there what were the challenges how was
the planing the execution to join the
culture love I'm bad any bad to make
sure that all that deal was conveyed
through the whole organization yeah well
that was that's good question because at
the time was right because that Emma
have to company I come from we had this
culture that was very ingrained in
everybody's mind you know has never
changed that's what's good 20 years good
times bad times I was the same very
basic things Interbrew the other company
the Belgium company had business in
Europe and Asia they grew by a quiet
existing businesses and they didn't have
a culture of its own so they were still
tolerating different ways of doing
things in different countries so when we
joined we said hey we have something
here that works it's not like a pilot
has been in place for 20 years and they
said yeah let's do it so it was very
easy because the tiny was right but
you're right sometimes in mergers and
acquisitions that's a problem for
example we have a business now that we
acquired I'm not going to say that the
country a big a big business I went
there before we signed the check and I
was amazed about the culture I said man
this is just like ours they say
everything to say they practice
everything we say they have a whole
bunch of talented people here great then
we merged you know what the problem is
that culture is based in one guy as
opposed to ours
I work out our culture not based on me
we created a system that has a life of
itself you know because a lot of people
you know they share the same mindset and
they know what to do in that one company
it's all centralized at the top and this
guy says yes and no to everything and
the culture comes from him so now in
this process of trying to get the things
back to more of a system people other
people doing doing it and be examples
but to your question we had to change a
lot of people you know we had to change
a lot of people because some people say
you know what I like what you're trying
to do I respect I understand but I'm not
up for it I don't like it not for me I
understand why you're doing it
the culture the hard work the folk is
the whole thing I mean the meritocracy
all this thing is great I understand for
you to build great come you need all
this I'm just not up for it so we
thought okay then we have to part ways
so yeah a lot of that happen yeah so
it's not like a lot of your leadership
is based on you being very self-aware of
how you're impacting and influencing
other people and for all the people who
don't have a touchy-feely class out
there who are reporting up to you and
your company how do you teach them to be
self-aware in the same way so that they
can grow and be leaders well that's a
good point
again we learned when we had that high
turnover thing I was saying that I had a
problem that we did they introduced we
learned that a lot of our people we're
not even using the basic things we had
in hand at the time at hand for example
we do twice a year everybody does that
performance evaluation and ours is a 90
minute I - I in a room you know both
ways feedback both ways and it's written
so they were not using that because at
the time we were growing very fast we're
promoting people at the age of 25 to be
sales leaders for 20 people at the age
of 25 years old and the guy would look
at the
and Sookie I like this people I don't
like these people out and that kind of
thing was happening as opposed to go
back and look at the records and try to
understand how this guy has been here
for 10 years has a track record has some
gaps has some development programs so
let me get engaged with him knowing all
this before I just say I don't like to
look out you know so we try to tell
people which right we have courses now
in the company because I said in order
the two options on literature 25-year
old guy will be the supervisor of
frontline people you can either wait for
five years and the guy will learn
because it's right you'll learn but the
costs will be so high of that learning
and we're not at school but shouldn't
pay to learn so it's a business the
learning should come in a different way
so what we did is we started to give
these people a little bit more knowledge
before they got to that position so in
our company we have programs that will
get people okay so if you think this
layer is the people that we'll be
feeding into the next layer let's try to
get these people some knowledge about
basic but their basic stuff while
coaching you know selecting good people
for example tell you one example and I
love to use sports analogy I'm not a
sports guy by the way but but I think
sports great for example coach can you
imagine the coach delegating the role of
recruiting team members to somebody else
can you imagine that but you know I
think companies that's that's done a lot
you need people you hire a consultant a
headhunter and not even the last
interview sometimes the guy responsible
for that division will go to you'll
delegate that to somebody else can you
imagine that in the sports I mean that's
somebody from the 49ers would delegate
okay you go out there you see what kind
of teams set up you get to tell me I'll
just sign the dotted line and we'll go
play I mean can I imagine that in
companies people do that you know so
those details you know sometimes you go
to managers and they say you're not
spending time with you for me a great
team you know and the guy says I don't
have time but people feel that it's
great if they have a busy agenda because
they were working a lot you know but if
you're not dedicating time to the main
drivers of the business
which is people you know what what are
you doing with your time you know so I
think the course is about this you know
it's about bringing people very common
sense that they would learn in five
years three years that we learned before
telling them in advance what we expect
from them and what their team is going
to expect from that from a good leader
yeah secondly how the perception of your
industry as somewhat blue-collar affects
your recruiting process at MBA schools
and other places yeah that's that's a
great point I think you're right when I
joined my company I was the only the
first and only NBA to join the company
and at first you know nobody knew nobody
care you know what the NBA was and and
because of meritocracy people even the
the guy who hired me said what do you
have an MBA all it means is that I
expect more from you that's all it means
and I expect that you're going to grow
faster but you have to earn that
today this industry's are more
sophisticated today even in beverage
companies consumer goods you do have a
lot of MBAs just because the business is
more global consumers are more tough on
us they expect more you have to have
better insights execute better in the
marketplace
otherwise you disappear so companies got
more sophisticated and they understand
the value of talent so today it's not a
problem 20 years ago you're right it
would be a little bit of a strange
animal to be an MBA in a consumer goods
company today no
yeah here have a dream and a simple
dream something that could be to guide
people to wake them up in the morning
but then you mentioned that today's
dream is to be best in class yes that
also sounds like something very general
and something that a lot of companies
would strive to and I'm not sure it
actually guides people or it would guide
me to to know what to do or you know to
be motivated it's more question thank
you so so how ya know what that's a
great point well we said our dream I
didn't want to talk about the company
but since you asked we say our dream is
to be the best for your company in a
better world and I'll explain both parts
of the sentence and that's measured by
profitability and we say that internally
and externally because we like the
pressure that that puts from the outside
world we're a public company on us so we
say we'll always have the highest margin
in the industry and so far we've
delivered but that puts a lot of
pressure on you but you know why we do
this just because of the people side of
the equation because you know what in
hiring talent you learn that people like
to be connected with companies that are
winning companies that are growing
companies that are profitable and
therefore can grow therefore can engage
in projects that other company could
that's the only reason it's great to
have results and all that but how this
connects to everything else is the
people side we learned that people most
people talented people they'd like to be
connected to winning teams companies
that are growing generating
opportunities for career growth as
opposed to companies that are shrinking
or not having good results so we say in
our company we say results is what keeps
the people engine running you know going
because people like to be connected
again human being very complex but one
of the things talented people like is to
be connected to something that's going
well and they want to be part of it so
and we think we always say life's too
short you want to be connected to a
company that's when to do something
better than the average that wants to
establish itself as the leader its
category
and that wants to leave a legacy so you
want build something that's bigger than
you that's the thing in our company
Eagles are very downplayed I mean we
don't like I mean we don't have
corporate jets I don't have an office
I share my table with my VPS we have
open offices and I sit with my marketing
guy on my left my sales guy on my right
finance guy in front of me the people
guy I mean I don't have a personal
assistant I share that with one of our
colleagues because we always say the
leaner the business the more money we'll
have at the end of the year to share and
because our compensation system is very
aggressive I don't want to spend money I
don't have a company car I don't care I
can buy my own car I don't I don't want
the company to give me free beer I can
buy my own beer so so I mean there are
so many perks in our company and that's
another reason why it's tough to hire
some people especially when you hire not
young people what you need to hire you
know a guy that has been 15 years in the
market because the guy comes and we
don't have a driver you don't have a
company car you don't have an office you
don't have you share table with
everybody else
why because we believe that interaction
creates value again it's not to be nice
that most people don't think that's nice
but it's it's really because I mean you
know the magic of having one table is
that you can have thirty two minute
meetings make make it possible if you go
in the in your calendar and the
Microsoft saying and it tried to book
two minute meetings
the thing won't take it it's programmed
only for 15 minutes when you sit around
a table like a trading desk our guys
came from an investment bank so they
were used to work in a trading desk
that's the environment I mean you're on
the phone across the table you're
talking about a promotion in the Ukraine
I just came back from the Ukraine I'll
say time tonight let me tell you this I
saw this in the Ukrainian you should be
aware of this look okay two minute
meeting that happens right there right
there talk about speed about information
about being the same page
some people don't like it because the
trade off it's more noisy you know but
the advantage is so much bigger you know
that we do it
soldiers parents talented people like
that maybe orchid people like to be
behind the door
I hope they forget me they don't like to
be exposed talented people is the
opposite they like to be where the
action is that like to be exposed they
like be part of the compass story
[Applause]